la personnalité de l'année de 2019 parce
que oui chers internautes retenez vos
larmes et ceci est notre dernière
émission
donc on en profite pour faire un petit
bilan cher nicolas domenach votre
événement de l'année avec mon événement
même si ça avait commencé en décembre
celle et gilet jaune c'est ce
surgissement et cette manifestation
d'une france fracture est ce qu'on
savait ce qu'on lisait mais c'est qu'on
ne ne l'identifié pas comme cela est au
fond la victoire qu'ils ont malgré tout
remporté même si on peut discuter de la
façon dont ça s'est passé et ça nous
sort on pense plus on regarde plus la
france comme avant et le président de la
république a dit qu'il s'en inspiraient
puisque ensuite nous avons eu grand
débat effectivement s'annonçait une
suite un acte 2 différents donc la
politique on a été transformé
radicalement et religieuse elle votre
événement de l'année de l'année c'est
l'incendié notre dame
parce que c'est ça mobilise et juste
précisément cette cette idée d'identité
français cette unité qu'on croyait
terminée depuis un certain nombre de
temps la société soudain n'est plus
apparu archipel is et comme selon la
formule consacrée
donc c'est vrai que ça a été à la fois
un événement triste et un événement beau
ce qui est terrible c'est qu'aujourd'hui
sur les ruines de notre dame
alors qu'on a eu le sentiment que
immédiatement dans le coeur de chaque
français vibrer l'âme d'un bâtisseur de
cathédrale tout le monde voulait donner
son obole pour leur construire et bien
aujourd'hui il y à des batailles des
batailles pour savoir là pour connaître
la façon et savoir si comment sera
construite sa cathédrale et on espère
que que l'esprit des bâtisseurs de
cathédrales enfin moi je l'espère ne ne
sera pas trahie j'ajoute même s'il reste
encore deux numéros du figaro magazine
je me permets de reprendre ma casquette
de patron de cette honorable journal
pour vous dire que pour nos lecteurs
c'est aussi de très loin l'événement le
plus important de l'année en tout cas ça
a été le numéro qui a suscité le plus de
le plus de ventes exceptionnelles dans
les kiosques mais mon avis importe moins
que celui de jérôme sainte-marie et
richard bryant n'a pas encore entendu
jérôme sainte-marie votre
votre événement de l'année beaucoup plus
temporel et même pratiquement politicien
je m'en excuse pour moi l'événement un
événement très important et plus en plus
importants et apprécié les récents ça a
été le terme semble-t-il le set très
durable saga du break site et ça a été
donc l'événement de l'année tout
simplement la victoire du parti de bruce
johnson aux élections législatives
britanniques
il y a quelques jours pourquoi et
pourquoi c'est un événement important
pour la france parce que déjà c'est une
information très importante et très
différente surtout de ce que les
français ont entendu par rapport à ce
que pensaient les britanniques du grec
cite ça fait trois ans qu'on nous
explique ils regrettent leur vote
apparemment c'est pas si massif que cela
et puis surtout ça a été dans cette
grande démocratie britannique ça a été
la preuve que les mouvements à l'oeuvre
un peu partout en europe y compris chez
nous ils le sont aussi avec
effectivement quelque chose qui
ressemble de moins en moins au clivage
gauche droite on avait faim enfin un
autre élément qui intéresse peut-être
aussi toute l'europe
c'est la crise sous toutes ses formes de
la gauche ce soit la social démocratie
ou bien les partis qui ont tenté le
populisme de gauche
et tout cela fait qu'effectivement sera
mon avis et conséquences durables y
compris sur notre vie politique
richard houis que votre événement de
l'année harrah's il est assez inattendu
doit dire mais c'est parler je voulais
vous parler de la crise des urgentistes
c'était ce hammam
mon événement de l'année c'est une grève
qui dure depuis quasiment dix mois enfin
plus de neuf mois en tout cas c'est une
grève dont on parle peu c'est un
mouvement social assez fort qui concerne
donc tous les agents d urgence et qui
s'est petit à petit étendu à l'hôpital
public
je trouve que c'est un peu le symbole de
cette révolte qui est la fois sourde qui
est celle des héros du quotidien mais
qui font pas du tout les plateaux de
télé de ce qu'on entend par des
conditions de vie qui sont les
conditions de travail qui sont de plus
en plus difficile des gens qui se
dévouent corps et âme de ce collectif
qui s'est monté call sûrement profiter
de l'expérience des gilets jaunes et
qu'on a bénéficié pour à la fois se
structurer s'organiser mais je trouve
que l'appel qu'ils ont lancées sur la
santé
le besoin de la santé de proximité sur
ce que c'est aujourd'hui que d'être
accueilli en urgence sur les premiers
accueils le trouve que c'est un moment
important qu'on n'a pas beaucoup entendu
parce que c'est fait pas partie de ces
mouvements qui éclatent dans les médias
et pourtant et pourtant plus de neuf
mois de mobilisation dans les urgences
et pas dans un service d'urgence dans
plus de 250 service par 280 service je
trouve que ça a raconté beaucoup de
choses sur notre état aujourd'hui de la
santé de l'inquiétude par rapport à la
santé
nos internautes se prennent au jeu et
nous donnent leurs événements
l'événement qui les a le plus marqués
claudius cloudy c'est la mise en examen
de françois bayrou
nicole 0 suit nicolas domenach puisque
elle cite les gilets jaunes babineau
suis gabriel cuisine en parlant de notre
dame et romain nous parle de lusine
lubrizol en flammes et ses conséquences
alors vous à poser une autre question
qui est votre personnalité de l'année
pour vous gabriel cluzel c'est boris
johnson dont on vient de parler
jérôme sainte-marie ne sais pas si c'est
pour les mêmes raisons enfin un homme de
droite qui était l'une c'est ça que vous
pensez non mais je trouve que ce
personnage déjà et très anglais
un peu foutraque et mal coiffée et dont
on n'attendait pas une issue pareil on
s'est moqué finalement de lui c'est un
peu il pour être joué par hugh grant
ouailles et s'il y avait une une fiction
là c'était pas quatre mariages et un
enterrement c'était quatre enterrements
du bric cité puis finalement un mariage
il a réussi donc je trouve que ce
personnage en effet à résister ils
allaient le break site tout le monde
disait qu'on s'en sortira pas c'était
c'était la belle arlésienne et bien lui
il à dire et l'épée d'excalibur il a
réussi là où là theresa may bien que
bien coiffé avait échoué j'ai trouvé que
c'était un personnage tout à fait tout à
fait intéressant petit témoignage sur la
coiffure de boris diaw à 10 leçons que
j'ai eu l'occasion une fois de
l'interroger sur une chaîne de
télévision est la dernière chose qu'il a
faite avant de prendre l'antenne c'est
de se décoiffer
donc en fait il est savamment décoiffés
nicolas domenach vassalité de l'année
c'est mon idole greta vie est
regrettable bergues
je savais que je vous ferais plaisir en
choisissant cette jeune femme qui est
vraiment plus qu une lanceuse d'alert
d'invoquer un courage exceptionnel mais
qui est une une lumière pour une
espérance pour toute une génération
nouvelle et ce qui me fascine aussi
celles à la violence des réactions
contre elle ce qu'elle provoque chez des
gens pourtant très intelligent vraiment
très respectable de
pascal bruckner finkielkraut
etc et tutti quanti au fond parce que
c'est une sorcière moderne c'est à dire
que c'est une jeune femme qui refuse les
codes de la séduction c'est une jeune
tout court qui refuse d'être assigné au
silence est une c'est une asperge air
enfin en tout cas qui refusent d'aller
faire un atelier de macramé et qui parle
en s'inspirant des scientifiques et et
en disant aux adultes vous n'avez pas
fait le boulot
eh ben je dis chapeau est ce que j'offre
sainte-marie vous parlerai avec autant
de fougue et d'enthousiastes votre
personnalité de l'année absolument et je
faillis christophe castaner alors
pourquoi est-ce que c'est aussi mieux
j'ai noté ce que le disait nicolas
domenach greta sandaga est une lumière
et une espérance est ce que tu sauf qu'à
savoir aussi pourquoi elle choisit
christophe quel ce tonnerre parce qu'il
a su rétablir l'ordre public
certainement pas on commence l'année
avec les incidences la passerelle de
solférino à l'infini après semaine après
semaine on a envie à paris sous avec des
convois de police a dû vaincre imogène
etc
le npd des dizaines de milliers de bals
duel bd seront tirés tout cela policiers
lors de la rave on n'est toujours pas
rétabli est ce parce que il a amélioré
l'image des forces de l'ordre dans
l'opinion
certainement pas alors même que les
forces de l'ordre bénéficier d'une image
presque unanime aujourd'hui alors c'est
pour tes vraiment vite le est ce que
parce qu'il a fidélisé les forces de
l'ordre par rapport il a réconforté est
ce qu'il aura pas du tout au point que
juste avant un mouvement social majeur
est bien le rayonnement est obligé de
renoncer à sa promesse d'universalité la
réforme des retraites pour maintenir le
régime spécial de la police en espérant
comme ça
les accommoder non parce qu'il a montré
qu'une forme quelque chose de
profondément réconfortant d'un point de
vue moral et personnels se montrait à
quel point la loyauté peut être
récompensés en ce monde qu'on écrit que
si dur qu'est la vie politique est bien
effectivement la loyauté totale au chef
de l'état a été récompensé malgré ce que
l'on pouvait juger de la réalité de son
option
et bien voilà qui est dit rich abric
vous aurez le mot de la fin votre
personnalité de l'année est originaire
de ce qui est peut-être le plus beau
département français l'aveyron
la même oui moi j'évolue cité pierre
soulages c'est son centenaire c'est
l'exposition au louvre ben voilà c'est
effectivement ce jeune ruthénois qui
n'est une première fois donc à rodez
mais qui renaît une deuxième fois avec
la peinture une peinture à la fois
radicale fait doutre noir mais aussi de
beaucoup de lumière dans ses dernières
interviews dit qu'il a encore l'envi de
créer l envie de peindre je trouve ça
assez formidable et pour tous ceux qui
le connaissent ou qui l'approchent
notamment dans l'aveyron c'est quelqu'un
toujours d'accessible et qui aime à
raconter ce qu'il fait et comment il l'a
fait et souffre que c'est assez
passionnant mais voilà on passe de
quelqu'un qui est né dans une petite
ville d'une vingtaine de milliers
d'habitants et qui arrive à toucher
l'universel avec son art je trouve ça
remarquable et je voulais signaler merci
beaucoup et nous laisserons le dernier
mot de l'année
un internaute christian léon qui dit la
personnalité de l'année pour lui c'est
emmanuel macron car ajoute-t-il quoi
qu'on en pense il est toujours en
sauvant il est toujours au centre pardon
voilà ce sera le mot de la fin
nous aurons la grille